obrigado por virem obrigando seu caminho
um monte para um monte de lugar anos
séculos milênios
estava com saudade de vocês que bom que
vocês aceitaram um convite de vir nós
nos encontramos
muito obrigado acredito em anjos
sim é o que remete os anjos manjo uma
palavra que vem aqui quando fãs cuida
protege não pense nessa perspectiva um
cachorro que nos acompanha a gente está
com um pouquinho de medo vira um anjo
não quando quando estão os 40 graus e um
sol de rachar e está caminhando e acho
uma árvore ela vira um anjo também
porque nos dá sombra
nós tivemos agora nesse momento aqui
nesse teatro algum de nós só
simbolicamente algum tipo de ataque o
tenhamos um mal súbito tem vira o nosso
anjo pintado lado tão presente que vocês
olhem o anjo esquerda mão para o anjo
que bom que agora está todo mundo em
anjo todo mundo velho conhecida
sinta-se abraçado pelas minhas palavras
porque o intuito do que eu venho falar
aqui é como um carinho tem várias formas
de expressar amor e carinho eu vou usar
as palavras elas chegam com um abraço
que o meu objetivo daqui de cima que
vocês sintam bem sintam tranquilos e e
entre aí ficam dentro de vocês porque é
um lugar maravilhoso é o melhor talvez
que a gente pode fazer está dentro de si
mesmo
já quem já desmistificou que ele
acredita em anjos acredita em magia e
essa energia a minha a minha a minha
mensagem a uma magia a magia por aí
a magia pode ser que a gente diz que
está dentro de nós está dentro de nós
eu posso tentar explicar aquela
capacidade que nós temos de acessar uma
magia que está esperando no campo
pô tá aí existe uma magia esperando que
a gente se parece que faça coisas
mágicas e eu vou falar sobre a magia
sobre a sobre isso
minha jornada de descobrimento pessoal
que serve para me curar e contínuo para
inspirar vocês no caminho sagrado de
vocês o qual o irã se convida à
descoberta da magia de acessar magia a
um combinado não tem vitimização
eu não sou vítima universo é a moral a
cada um tocando viver o que precisa para
o seu o seu caminhar que influencia no
caminho dos outros então não tem
vitimização e não é uma verdade absoluta
dentro de um milhão de possibilidades a
gente vai dar uma conversada sobre uma e
assim eu vivi o meu auschwitz meu campo
de concentração em guaporé na serra
gaúcha não é diminuir se eu falar ou
aumentar em 1 ao time um campo de
concentração foi sistematicamente
violentado pelo meu pai teve a arma
apontada pelo meu país na minha cabeça e
eu ganhei um grande presente o presente
que chegou de lima expulsar de casa e eu
sentir raiva ea raiva foi maravilhosa me
trouxe aqui eu tenho paz fundo
conversando com vocês também pela raiva
e kibon raiva porque o universo não tem
moralidade uma lei da natureza o
movimento e que faz mover não importa se
tem que se mover
eu mesmo vi pela vai vai provar o meu
pai que podia ser melhor que ele tinha
sido muito mal comigo errado e me
expulsar de casa e pela raiva eu estudei
me formei engenheiro de sistemas da
microsoft com 17 anos tive na vida
profissional resolvida
montei uma empresa com 19 anos de
segurança de internet alguma coisa
comandante hacker na escola cristo bem e
aí chegou um outro pacote
aos 30 anos o pacotão assim dos correios
sentimento de vazio e aí só que a vida
só isso tudo que eu passei porque eu
sofri que é o que a vida que eu quero
buscar o que eu quero fazer
eu vou chegar aos 80 anos de vida que a
vida foi pelos dedos e eu não fiz valer
principalmente o fato de ter sobrevivido
eu tinha que retribuir o que entender
melhor
então o que eu fiz que hoje é fácil
falar na hora não era tão
foi uma coisa mais se largasse jogar eu
decidi aos 30 anos vender todos os meus
pertences dar de presente o que eu tinha
que podia ser doado e fui morar no botão
e comecei a uma viagem de três anos uma
viagem de três anos em verdade dentro de
mim viajar pelo mundo por três anos por
várias situações países lugares medos
anseios fez eu entrando pra dentro de
mim e tirando as máscaras de cantando
esse personagem tentando ver quem era eu
de verdade mesmo e era o que eu acredito
que há uma uma parte muito sábia de mim
talvez não tão consciente e racional mas
uma série de aspectos um certo aspecto
muito muito sábia de queria que eu me
conhecesse um pouco melhor o tratamento
aqui com vocês hoje eu tenho um relógio
tá sempre no horário certo nunca atrasa
nunca adianta este momento e eu tive que
aprender está cada vez mais no momento
um momento que eu tô aqui é o que eu
posso ter um maravilhoso na vida é a
cada lugar ninguém meter um aprendizado
eu fui morar no botão o aprendizado do
botão a camada da cebola foi aprender a
estar sozinha porque eu não sabia tornou
insuportável estar sozinha foi muito
importante está longe no botão e
aprender a suportar a minha companhia
foi um grande aprendizado na islândia
foi a primeira vez na minha vida que me
permitissem do brasileiro num lugar
maravilhoso como o brasil me base bacajá
fica bobo com a beleza natural desse
país
e aí eu percebi que eu sou parte de
alguma coisa e aquele sentimento de
vazio aos 30 anos
aqui é um grande remédio perceber que eu
sou parte da natureza que estava muito
bom francisco de assis ghirardi assis
chamar tudo de irmão irmã perceber que
nós somos conectados vocês sabiam que a
maravilha que lindo que quando surgiram
as flores surgiu ovário
mas temos que surgiu às flores no reino
vegetal surgiu no ovário no reino animal
que são as flores se não há vários que
linda conexão que têm entre tudo e eu
sou parte disso eu sou pela água
eu sou esse verde isso tudo é muito bom
sentir conectando diminui o vazio
muito muito muito vazio vietnã
aí o mapa do vietnã vietnã me ensinou
que eu sou potencialmente muito muito
muito maluco louco eu tô aqui na frente
me despedindo de vocês eu sou pirata ao
mesmo tempo também tem capacidade de
escolher a sobriedade é muito relativo
tudo isso mas eu fui capaz que morou no
botão tomando café da manhã e meditando
todas as manhãs com os monges
eu sou um rapaz que foi no vietnã
comprei uma moto sem saber andar
isso agora é um homem qualquer curva
então é muito importante reconhecer a
sombra ea luz a loucura ea sobriedade o
bom eo mau porque facilita o processo de
não ficar apontando pra fora
nada do que tem lá fora e pra aos civis
e para os campos de concentração de de
matança do camboja me fez ver que eu
também sou tão mal quanto aquelas
pessoas e isso ajuda a entrar aqui onde
importa de verdade fora todo mundo
executa papéis
eu não coloco mais etiqueta do bom e do
mau estamos todos juntos executando
papéis grande hitler tudo papel
importantíssimo para a nossa trem da
cidade transformada em cidade e sutileza
transformar a sombra em luz avançar todo
mundo executando papéis sagrados isso é
muito bom
é o reconhecimento pra mim de que eu sou
todos os papéis e posso escolher qual
quero nem de repente projetar e
expressão é o caminho de santiago de
compostela me ensinou que aquela que
caminhar com a mochila leve facilita
bastante porque dói dói muito e que será
mochila leve na vida não
também me ensinou a ficar um pouco mais
nos dias e não esperar nenhuma
felicidade lugar nenhum promessa a opção
são 30 dias
oitocentos e poucos quilômetros
caminhando e você espera que a
felicidade está no último dia e você tem
que aprender na marra não olha a placa
porque com dor no joelho uma placa de
800 quilômetros a pior coisa do mundo
então você começa a viver os dias um por
um
a vida resumida num dia a felicidade as
amarguras os encontros e desencontros a
emoção tudo resumido veio carne diz a
vida contida hermeticamente
dentro de um dia ele tem alguma coisa
interessante a a última parte da minha
viagem foi mais uma loucurinha parané
pro balancear que era eu comprei
conseguiu uma moto uma uma moto de 150
cilindradas foi até o alasca e decidir
de ser de moto do círculo polar ártico
até o brasil e o que eu aprendi com essa
viagem de oito meses de 22 mil
quilômetros e 15 países que qualquer
loucura que não é pra dar certo porque
não era pra dar certo e por que não é
romântico dói dói bombom dói o peito
andar como tinha tem todo tipo de
perigos mas qualquer loucura do fato de
eu não fui só eu falar não tem carteira
de motorista de moto eu não sei mexer
mota uma experiência do vietnã
eu não sei trocar pneu de moto eu não
tinha mapa não tinha gps ferramenta peça
de reposição nada
não era pra dar certo é de verdade uma
grande loucura tô aqui com toda minha
sobriedade autoridade no tema dizendo
que é uma grande loucura mas tinha um
grande sentido um grande propósito eu
acordava todas as manhãs e visitava
escolas e as escolas era o meu propósito
com essa escola de educação alternativa
pelo mundo
eu vim falar sobre a magia ea magia o
que eu expressei
depois de fazer um trabalho muito
importante de entrar não está resolvido
não terminei nada só sentei à condição
de entrar para dentro de mim e eu não
saio mais agora só que fazer visitas
meus irmãos continuamente mas aqui é um
túnel que eu entro e atravessar a
jornada à noite escura da alma o inverno
da alma às vezes sombrio é escuro e frio
já cheira mal mas de cantar tirar as
caixas do sol tão tirar as caixas do
porão e descobrir que depois de toda
essa limpeza tem alguma coisa tem uma
pérola tem uma luz tem uma magia que não
é uma ciência uma capacidade de acessar
uma magia que está no universo esperando
dizendo assim ei começa a realizar
expressar as coisas mágicas que o mundo
espera de você
essa é a magia
cidade conectada com esse campo
maravilhoso que espera que a gente
execute uma virtude humana
uma das grandes virtudes humanas da
expressadas pelos gregos a capacidade de
reconhecer e expressar a beleza
reconhecer e expressar a beleza estamos
prontos
eu vim aqui convidar vocês e vou
compartilhar por inspiração na magia
ainda uma escola que que foi expressada
só uma ferramenta que resolveu expressar
nem com todo o meu carinho e uma escola
que com essas propostas imagina uma
escola que não tem a sala de aula que
não tenha a divisão de turmas que não
tenha provas que não tenha competição
nós por não ter provas já
automaticamente nos elimina a competição
onde os estudantes pequenos mestres têm
liberdade para escolher o que aprender o
que acessar o que expressar esse é o
bosque online é um movimento social é
uma inspiração para os adultos dizendo
volte a ser criança volte a ser o gênio
que você era volte a se conecte expressa
sua divindade somos todos budas somos
todos christus somos todos cristina se
somos todos francisco de assis
somos todos maria montessori eu posso
dizer que eu quero ser como paulo freire
na educação eu me inspiro nós podemos
ser como essas pessoas
nós temos que assumir a responsabilidade
disso e ainda inspirar isso não era pra
ter dado certo chegar para o prefeito da
cidade e pedir esse bosque é o terra
média dos hobbits é lindo lindo lindo
lindo e perfeito eu quero aquele bosque
lá naquele lugar lá ele olhou thiago eu
tenho muito medo do que você está
propondo mas eu te apoio pra mim essa
magia não era pra ter dado certo como
descer de moto do do alasca
a única avaliação na minha felicidade eu
morei no botão aprendiz conceitos de
felicidade interna bruta e percebi que
era isso que também aprender lá para
poder colocar em prática o que importa
na escola avaliar a felicidade dos
envolvidos não só das crianças
de todos que todo mundo eu deixo para
vocês uma pergunta que sempre sempre
pessoa pra mim não assim tão formatada
desde pequeninho o que minha alma se
expressar através da minha existência
nesse dia que nosso reencontro que diz o
poeta que respostas matam perguntas
então não vamos matar ela deixa ela
vinha que a minha alma sei expressar
através da minha resistência a uma coisa
linda maravilhosa por vocês expressarem
por nós pensarmos juntos passo que vocês
derem vai influenciar diretamente em mim
que linda o que eu dou e o caminho
influencia em vocês
e essa grande sacada tão todo mundo
junto caminhando junto em doha diante
juntos
juntos estamos aqui para cooperar
as pessoas às vezes também me felicitam
muito sempre me felicitaram pelos meus
alcance pelo menos conquistas parabéns
tiago ser um vencedor e eu tenho
realmente com todo carinho e vontade de
de compartilhar puxa mas eu não vim aqui
pra ganhar de ninguém
não vim mesmo sem demagogia alguma quero
cooperar cooper a aime é compartilhar em
que tinha a língua dos antigos incas do
povo que tinha mas compartilhar
traduzido para o português ficam verbo
mas para eles é uma organização social
de cooperação e me inspirou muito a aqui
a dar esse nome
eu estive na numa comunidade na
argentina nas cerdas de córdoba e um
helinho me perguntou um senhorzinho
muito muito idoso querido que eu tenho
eu tenho ele diariamente na minha
lembrança tiago você já sentiu triste
nostálgico eu tô toda hora pois é olha
só essa nostalgia essa tristeza e
saudade que você tem de quem você sabe
que é da saudade daqui a gente realmente
sabe que a gente é ser mágico que a
gente é ser sublime do gênio que é capaz
de fazer coisas maravilhosas como
qualquer gênero que a gente possa
imaginar aqui e eu vim convidado para
assumir a responsabilidade
muito muito muito importante e bem
prática
vivemos um lugar maravilhoso dessa
grande rio de areia chamada terra que
orbita o sol o sol pequenininho
até então tinha pequenininho e só porque
ele é sozinho tem muitas estrelas que
são são juntas e nós somos abençoados de
estar vivendo nesse momento nesse lugar
da terra e quem sabe ligando com esse
sentimento de bênção temos sim uma
possibilidade nos conectar com uma
grande energia que a gratidão e depois
dessa energia um passinho mais e nos
conectar com a responsabilidade a
gratidão pode nos levar com um
sentimento de responsabilidade que
estamos prontos para começar a executar
magia no mundo a realizar a magia está
esperando e pedindo eu vim aqui convidar
vocês porque sozinho não tem graça
é importante fazer todo mundo junto eu
estive em moçambique e os pequeninhos as
criancinhas quando se despedia da aula
na escola eles diziam profite água tira
até se é estamos juntos no dialeto
tribal deles então diretor s
obrigado por virem estamos conectados
pra sempre
obrigado